hello everyone welcome back this is part
five in our series on distributed word
representations we're going to be
talking about dimensionality reduction
techniques we saw in the previous
screencast that re-weighting is a
powerful tool for finding latent
semantic information in count matrices
we're going to push that even further
the promise of dimensionality reduction
techniques is that they can capture
higher order notions of co-occurrence
corresponding to even deeper sorts of
semantic relatedness
there's a wide world of these
dimensionality reduction techniques i've
chosen three that we're going to focus
on as interesting representatives of a
much larger space we'll look at latent
semantic analysis which is a classic
linear method then we'll talk about auto
encoders a newer powerful deep learning
mode for learning to reduce dimensional
representations and then finally glove
which is a simple yet very powerful
method that as you'll see has a deep
connection to pointwise mutual
information and then i'm going to going
to close by talking briefly about
visualization which is another kind of
dimensionality reduction technique that
we might use for very different purposes
so let's begin with latent semantic
analysis a classic method the paper is
due to dear wester at all 1990 that's a
classic paper that really made a splash
uh it's one of the most lsa is now one
of the oldest most widely used
dimensionality reduction techniques not
only in scientific research but also an
industry i think it was really
eye-opening for people at the time of
the paper's appearance to see just how
powerful this technique could be
especially in context of involving
information retrieval
the method is also known as known as
truncated singular value decomposition
and i'll explain why that is in a second
the final thing i want to say at this
high level is just that lsa remains a
very powerful baseline especially when
part of a pipeline of other re-weighting
methods so it should probably be in your
results table and it's often very
difficult to beat
now i think we can't in the time
allotted to us cover all of the
technical details surrounding latent
semantic analysis in my experience this
would be kind of the culmination of a
full course in linear algebra but i do
think i can convey the guiding
intuitions and that will help you with
responsible use of the method
so let's imagine that we have this
simple two-dimensional vector space
model i've got four points a b c and d
arrayed out in this two-dimensional
space
i think we're all familiar with fitting
linear models which capture the largest
source of variation in the data that's
this orange line here
the perspective i would encourage you to
take is that we can think of that linear
regression model as performing
dimensionality reduction in that it
encourages us to project points like b
and c down onto that line
and in projecting them down onto that
line essentially in abstracting away
from their point of variation along the
y axis we can see the sense in which
they are abstractly similar they're
close together in this reduced
dimensional space
now with the linear model we captured
the source of greatest variation of this
little data set in a high dimensional
space we could continue fitting
lines to other sources of variation in
the data other axes of variations so
here's a blue line here that captures
the next dimension and we could again
project points like a and c down onto
that line and that would capture the
abstract sense in which a and c although
very spread out along the x dimension
are very close together along the y
dimension and of course if we had more
dimensions in this vector space model we
could continue to perform these cuts and
dimensionality reductions capturing ever
more abstract notions of similarity
along these different axes and that is
in essence what lsa is going to do for
us in our really large matrices
the fundamental method as i said is
singular value decomposition this is a
theorem from linear algebra that says
any matrix of dimension m by n can be
decomposed into the product of three
matrices t s and d
with the
dimensions given here's a more concrete
example
start with this matrix of dimension
three by four we learned a term matrix
which is full of length normalized
orthogonal vectors
we have this matrix of singular values
along the diagonal they are organized
from largest to smallest corresponding
to the greatest to least source of
variation in the data
and then we have the document or column
wise matrix which is also length
normalized and orthogonal in its space
and the theorem here is that we can
reconstruct a from these three matrices
of course we don't want to precisely
reconstruct a that probably wouldn't
accomplish very much for us
but what we can do is use this to learn
reduced dimensional representations of a
by being selective about which term and
singular value dimensions we include in
the model
let me walk you through an example of
how that happens and first let me
motivate this a little bit with an
idealized linguistic case so i've got up
here a word by document matrix its
vocabulary is gnarly wicked awesome lame
and terrible and the conceit of my
example is that both gnarly and wicked
are positive terms so they tend to
co-occur with awesome and not co-occur
with lame and terrible however gnarly
and wicked never occur in the same
document the idea is that gnarly is a
slang positive term associated with the
west coast of the united states and
wicked is a slang
term associated with the east coast of
the united states in virtue of that
idealized dialect split they never occur
in the same document but nonetheless
they have similar neighbors in this
vector space and that's the kind of
abstract notion of co-occurrence that we
want to capture
if we simply use our standard distance
measures and re-weighting techniques and
so forth we will not capture that more
abstract notion of co-occurrence here
distances in this raw vector space
gnarly awesome terrible and wicked
wicked is farther away from gnarly even
than terrible is so we've got a
sentiment confusion and really just not
the result we were shooting for
so we perform
singular value decomposition into these
three matrices and then the truncated
part is that we're going to consider
just the first two dimensions of the
term matrix corresponding to these two
singular values capturing the top two
sources of variation in the data
so we multiply those together and we get
this reduced dimensional matrix down
here
two by the size of the vocabulary and if
we do distance measures in that space
just as we were hoping gnarly and wicked
are now neighbors the method has
captured that more abstract notion of
having the same neighbors as the other
word
in the previous lecture i encourage you
to think about what you're doing to a
matrix when you perform some kind of
re-weighting scheme let's extend that to
these dimensionality reduction
techniques so here's a picture of what
lsa does starting with a raw count
distribution over here
if i just run lsa on that rockcount
distribution i get what looks also like
a very difficult distribution of values
the sale values are very spread out and
they have a lot of the mass centered
around zero here corresponding to the
peak and the raw counts over here near
zero as well so that doesn't look like
we've done very much in terms of taming
the kind of untractable skewed
distribution we started with
however if instead we take the raw
counts and first feed them through pmi
which as we saw before gives us this
nice distribution of values highly
constrained along the x-axis
and then we run lsa we retain a lot of
those good properties the values are
somewhat more spread out but still
nicely distributed this looks like a
much happier input to downstream
analytic methods than the top version
here and i think this is beginning to
show that it can be powerful to pipeline
re-weighting and dimensionality
reduction techniques
another note i would want to make how do
you choose the dimensionality for lsa it
has this variable k corresponding to the
number of dimensions that you keep
if you read the literature on lsa they
often imagine this kind of what i've
called the dream scenario where you plot
the singular values
and you see that a lot of them are very
large and then there's a sudden drop off
and if you do see this then it's obvious
that you should pick the point of the
sudden drop off as your k so here you
would pick k is 20 and you'd be
confident that you had captured almost
all the variation in your data in the
reduced dimensional space you were
creating
unfortunately
for the kinds of matrices and problems
that we're looking at i really never see
the dream scenario what i see looks
something much more like this where you
have kind of a sudden drop off early and
then a long decline and maybe a sudden
drop off at the end and it's basically
totally unclear where in the space you
should pick k
and the result is that k is often chosen
kind of empirically as a hyper parameter
tuned against whatever problem you're
actually trying to solve
if in doing this work you do see the
dream scenario please do write to me it
would be very exciting to see that
happen
lsa is just one of a large family of
matrix decomposition methods um here's a
list of a few of them and a lot of them
are implemented in scikit-learn in its
decomposition library and i would
encourage you to try them out and just
see how they perform on problems that
you're trying to solve
and finally here's a little bit of code
vsm.lsa
so with k set to 100 gives me back a
reduced dimensional version of that
matrix keeping the same vocabulary of
course but now with only 100 column
dimensions
let's move to auto encoders this will be
a point of contracts with lsa because
this is a much more powerful method
so here's the overview auto encoders are
a flexible class of deep learning
architectures for learning reduce
dimensional representations if you want
to hear much more about this classroom
models i would encourage you to read
chapter 14 of the good fellow at all
book deep learning it has a lot of
details and a lot of variations on this
theme
here is the basic autoencoder model the
input would be the say the vectors from
our the rows in our matrices so this
could be the counts or something that
you've done to the counts
those are fed through a hidden layer of
representation and then the goal of this
model is try to is to try to literally
reconstruct the input
now that might be trivial if h had the
same dimensionality as x but the whole
idea here is that you're going to feed
the input through a very narrow pipe and
then try to reconstruct the input
given that you're feeding it through a
potentially very very narrow pipe it's
unlikely that you'll be able to fully
reconstruct the inputs but the idea is
that the model will learn to reconstruct
the important sources of variation in
performing this auto encoding step
and then when we use these models for
representation learning in the mode that
we've been in for this unit the
representation that we choose is this
hidden unit here we typically don't care
about what was reconstructed on the
output but rather only about the hidden
reduced dimensional representation that
the model learned this slide has a bunch
of other annotations on it and the
reason i included them is that the
course repository includes a reference
implementation of an autoencoder and all
the other deep learning models that we
cover in pure numpy and so if you wanted
to understand all of the technical
details of how the model was constructed
and optimized you could use this as a
kind of cheat sheet to understand how
the code works
i think the fundamental idea that you
want to have is simply that the model is
trying to reconstruct its inputs the
error signal that we get is the
difference between the reconstructed and
actual input and that error signal is
what we use to update the parameters of
the model
final thing i would mention here is that
it could be very difficult for this
model if you feed in the raw count
vectors down here they have very high
dimensionality and their distribution is
highly skewed as we've seen so it can be
very productive to do a little bit of
re-weighting and maybe even
dimensionality reduction with lsa before
you start feeding inputs into this model
of course it could still be meaningful
even if you've done lsa as a
pre-processing step to learn a hidden
dimensional representation because this
model is presumably capable of learning
even more abstract notions than lsa is
in virtue of its non-linearity at this
hidden layer
and here's a bit of code just showing
how this works using both the reference
implementation that i mentioned as well
as a faster and more flexible torch auto
encoder which is also incorrect included
in the course repository i think the
only interface thing to mention here is
that these models have a fit method like
all the other machine learning models
for this but those the fit method
returns that hidden dimensional
representation the target for our
learning in this context which is a bit
non-standard but it's the intended
application
for this kind of representation
the other thing i would mention is so
let's see how well the auto encoder is
performing this is the raw distances in
the giga5 matrix for finance this is the
count matrix it doesn't look great
if we run the autoencoder directly on
the count matrix it looks a little
better but it's still not excellent
if we think of this as part of a
pipeline where we first done positive
point wise mutual information and then
lsa at dimension 100 and then done the
auto encoding step it starts to look
like a really good and interesting
semantic space and i think that's
pointing out the power of including the
auto encoder in a larger pipeline of
pre-processing on the count matrices
okay let's turn to glove or global
vectors for the final major unit for
this screencast
here's a brief overview glove was
introduced by um jeffrey pennington
richard socher and chris manning a
stanford team in 2014.
roughly speaking the guiding idea here
is that we want to learn vectors for
words such that the dot product of those
vectors is proportional to the log
probability of co-occurrence for those
words and i'll elaborate on that in a
second
for doing computational work we can rely
on the implementation torchglove.pi
which is in the course repo i'll mention
that there's also a reference
implementation in bsn.pi it's very slow
but it kind of transparently implements
the core glove algorithm so it could be
interesting to inspect and then if
you're doing practical work with really
large corporate and really large
vocabularies i would encourage you to
use the glove team cm limitation it's an
outstanding software artifact that will
allow you to learn lots of good
representations quickly
and that kind of brings me to my last
point i just want to mention that the
glove team was among the first teams in
nlp to release not just data and code
but pre-trained model parameters
everyone does that these days but it was
rare at the time and i think this team
is kind of really
forward thinking and seeing the value of
releasing these centralized resources
and a lot of really interesting work
happened
with glove vectors as a foundation
all right so let's think about the
technical aspects of this model this is
the glove objective and you're going to
see
point-wise mutual information kind of
creep into this picture in an
interesting way
so this is equation six from the paper
it's kind of an idealized objective for
the glove model and it says what i said
before we have a row vector and a column
vector
i wi and w k we're going to get their
dot product and the goal is to learn
to have that dot product be proportional
to the log of the probability of
co-occurrence of word i and word k
where the probability of co-occurrence
is defined in the way that we defined it
before when we were talking about row
normalization it's just done in log
space this is the co-occurrence count
this is the sum of all the counts along
that row and basically in log space
we're just dividing this value by this
value
so keep that in mind now the reason they
have only the row represented is that in
the paper they're assuming that the rows
and columns in the underlying count
matrix are identical and so we don't
need to include both however if we did
allow that the row and context could be
different we would just elaborate
equation 6 to have a slightly different
denominator right we would have the
product of the row sum and the column
sum and take the log of that and
subtract that out
and that would be kind of our goal for
learning these dot products here
but aha this is where pmi sneaks in
because that simply is the pmi objective
right where we stated that as the log of
the probability of co-occurrence divided
by the product of the row and the column
probabilities here they've just stated
exactly that calculation in log space
and these are numerically equivalent by
the equivalence of log of x over y being
the same as log of x minus the log of y
so that's the deep connection that i was
highlighting between glove and pmi and i
think that's really interesting because
it shows that fundamentally we're
testing a very similar hypothesis using
very similar notions of row and column
context
now the glove team doesn't just stop
there
the glove objective is actually much
more interesting as an elaboration of
that core that core pmi idea but it's
worth having pmi in mind because it's
there throughout this presentation
in the paper they state this is a kind
of idealized objective where we're going
to have the dot product as i said before
and two bias terms and the goal will be
to make that equivalent to the log of
the co-occurrence count
that has some undesirable properties
from the point of view of machine
learning so they propose in the end a
weighted version of that objective
you can see we still have the dot
product of the row and the column
vectors and two bias terms we're going
to subtract out the log of the
co-occurrence count
and take the square of that and that's
going to be weighted by f of the
co-occurrence count
where f is a function that you can
define by hand and what they do in the
paper is that it was two parameters x
max and alpha
for any count that is above x max we're
going to set it to one to kind of
flatten out all the really large counts
everything that's below x max we will
take as a proportion of x max with some
exponential scaling that's specified by
alpha that's the function there and
typically alpha is set to 0.75 and x max
200 but i encourage you to be critical
in thinking about both those choices and
how they relate to your data i'll return
to that in a second
so glove really has these three hyper
parameters the learned dimensional the
dimensionality of the representations
x max which is going to have this
flattening effect and alpha which is
going to scale the values right so
here's an example of how those are
interacting
x max and alpha if i start with this
vector 199 75 10 and 1
the the function f as we specified it is
going to flatten that out into 1 99 81
18 and 0.03
you should just be aware that that kind
of flattening is happening
so glove learning so it's kind of
interesting to think about analytically
about how love manages to learn
interesting representations and one
thing that might be on your mind is the
question can it actually learn higher
order notions of co-occurrence that's
been the major selling point of this
lecture i gave that example involving
gnarly wicked with lsa is glove going to
be able to do that right we could just
pose that as a question
so let's start that and see what happens
see how this works the loss calculations
for glove this is kind of a simplified
version of the derivative of the model
um
and we're going to show how glove
manages to pull gnarly and wicked toward
awesome in that little little idealized
space that i used before i'm going to
leave out the bias terms for simplicity
but we could bring those in
and so here's the how this is going to
proceed what i've done just for this
idealized example is begin in a glove
space where wicked and gnarly are as far
apart as i could make them so as
different as i could possibly make them
i've got awesome and terrible and
awesome is kind of close to gnarly
already what you'll see is that after
just one iteration of the model what has
happened is that wicked and gnarly have
been pulled toward awesome and that's
just the kind of effect that we wanted
that's the sense in which glove can
capture these higher order notions of
co-occurrence
just in a little more detail you might
want to study this on your own but the
high level overview of exactly how that
learning happens proceeds as follows we
start from these counts up here and the
crucial assumption i'm making is that
wicked and gnarly never co-occur
but they occur a lot with awesome
awesome will be kind of the
gravitational pull that makes gnarly and
wicked look similar
keep in mind that because of that
function f by and large with glove we're
dealing not with the raw counts but
rather with the re-weighted matrix and
that preserves this property that they
never co-occurred it gives differently
scaled values for the rest of the
co-occurrence or pseudo-co-occurrence
probabilities
all right and then here's so here's what
we're going to track this is the gnarly
vector in zero and you can see i've made
them as far apart as i could they're
kind of opposed to each other
we're going to see how they get pulled
toward awesome in the context factor
so this is that loss calculation i have
just plugged in all the values here and
you can see that we get this initial set
of losses
that's after one iteration we update the
weight matrices and we perform one more
round of learning and you can see that
both of these models the values here are
getting larger corresponding to get
getting pulled closer and closer toward
awesome and you can see that graphically
happening over here in these plots on
the left and as i do more iterations of
the glove model this effect is just
going to strengthen corresponding to
wicked and gnarly getting pulled toward
awesome and away from terrible as a
result of these underlying counts and i
take this as good evidence that glove
like the other methods we've discussed
is capable of capturing those higher
order notions of co-occurrence that
we're so interested in pursuing with
these methods
let's close the loop also we have those
central questions what is glove doing to
our underlying spaces with glove because
of the design of the matrix we have to
begin from
word by word co-occurrence matrices of
counts
so we begin with these raw count values
and gloves one-stop shopping it's going
to take us all the way to these reduced
dimensional representations and boy by
the criteria we've set up does glove do
an outstanding job this is the result of
running glove at dimension 50
and you can see that the values are
extremely well scaled between negative
two and two and nicely normally
distributed this is an outstanding input
to modern machine learning models and i
think this is probably a non-trivial
aspect of why glove has been so
successful as a kind of pre-trained
basis for a lot of subsequent machine
learning architectures
and then here's a little bit of code
just showing you how you can work with
these interfaces using our code base the
one thing i wanted to call out is that
i'm trying to be careful i have defined
this function percentage non-zero values
above
and you can set x max here and just feed
in a matrix and study what percentage of
the values in that matrix are going to
get flattened out to 1 as a result of
the x max that you've chosen and this
value really varies by the design of the
matrix if i feed in yelp 5
only about 5 of the values are getting
flattened out but if i feed in yelp 20
which is much denser and has much higher
counts
20 of the values are getting flattened
out to one you know if this number gets
too high the matrix might become
completely homogeneous and so should we
we should really be aware
of how the setting of x max is affecting
the kind of learning that we could even
be performing with glove and it might
turn out that this is even more
important than the number of iterations
or the dimensionality of the
representations that you learn
once you've made those choices though
the interface is pretty clear and the
fit method as with the autoencoder
returns the matrix of learned
representations that we want to use for
the current purposes
and then finally i've included a score
method and the score method is literally
just testing to see
how well the vectors that you've learned
correspond to the glove objective of
having the dot products be proportional
to the log of the co-occurrence
probabilities and you can get a score
for that we're doing pretty well here
let's say for a large empirical matrix
final section let's just say a bit about
visualization and this is our
dimensionality reduction technique in
the sense that the whole point is to try
to flatten out a very high dimensional
space into possibly two or three
dimensions
you have to recognize that inevitably
this will involve a lot of compromises
it's just impossible to capture all the
sources of variation in your underlying
matrix in just a few dimensions but
nonetheless this can be productive i
think it's especially valuable if you
pair it with some kind of hands-on
qualitative exploration using something
like bsm neighbors to understand at a
low level what your matrix encodes and
then the high-level visualizations can
be a kind of counterpart to that
there are many visualization techniques
and a lot of them are implemented in the
scikit manifold
package so i encourage you to use them
i'm going to show you some results from
tis knee which is which stands for t
distributed
stochastic neighbor embedding
there are lots of user guides there that
you can study for more details let me
just give you the high level this is to
sne run on our giga20 matrix i think
this is typical of pretty good output
from to so what we're seeing here is
some pockets of high density those are
areas of local coherence globally we
should be careful not to over interpret
this entire diagram because as you rerun
the model with different random seeds
you'll see that it gets kind of
reoriented in different parts are
correspondingly close to different other
parts but what you can count on pretty
reliably is that these local pockets of
co of coherence correspond to coherence
parts of the space that you've defined
and if you zoom in on them you can kind
of assess what the model has uncovered
so for this giga21 for example i think
we see prominent clusters corresponding
to things like cooking and conflict if
we do the same thing for our yelp matrix
again this looks pretty good in terms of
having some substructure that we could
analyze and if we zoom in we do see
clusters like positive terms and
negative terms corresponding to the
evaluative setting of these yelp reviews
so this is all very encouraging and
suggests that the underlying spaces have
some really interesting structure that
might be useful for subsequent analysis
and here are some code snippets we have
this simple wrapper around the scikit
disney implementation that will allow
you to flexibly work with this stuff
using the
count matrices from our unit and i'm
just mentioning here that it's pretty
easy if you wanted to color code the
words in your vocabulary say according
to a sentiment lexicon or some other
kind of lexicon that could be a way for
you to reveal exactly what structure
your model has been able to uncover with
respect to those underlying labels and
that can be useful